hey folks welcome to reality check to be
good or to be evil
now video games regularly presents us
with these two options do you spare the
town of weirdos you worship an atomic
bomb or do you set it off do you harvest
atom from a little sister or do you save
her
do you not punch the reports are in the
face or do you well you get the idea I
wish I've done that the first time we
met but what about once you've put the
controller down could being good or evil
in a game affect your actions in real
life now I don't know about you but when
I play games and I'm given a clear
choice of good or evil I tend to pick
the latter and take the dark side
now before you judge me I figure I spend
my entire real life trying at least to
pick the good options
this is logically inappropriate
sometimes moral choices and video games
aren't so explicitly obvious they can be
muddy ambiguous and uncertain and then
other times it's deciding whether or not
to put a live grenade in someone's pants
now it was this position of playing as a
definitively good or evil character that
was under investigation in a paper
published in the journal Psychological
Science Novi avatar the unintended
effect of virtual self representation on
behavior investigated whether or not the
way you represent yourself in video
games could affect how you behave
towards others in the real world so how
did they test this well by using
chocolate and chili sauce of course bear
with me
the test was split into two experiments
first off all 194 participants played a
game for five minutes in which they
assumed control of one of three avatars
one-third played as Superman the heroic
good guy one-third as Voldemort the
villainous evil guy and one-third as a
circle the neutral neutral guy now they
spent those five minutes of gaming
beating the living crap out of relevant
enemies however for the second part of
the test they were then asked to take
part in a completely new experiment a
blind taste test of both chocolate and
chili sauce with no suggestion that it
had anything at all to do with the
previous task after tasting both foods
participants were then asked to give
either chocolate or chili sauce
respectively to the future participants
who didn't actually exist but they
didn't know that subjects were told to
pour an unspecified amount of their
chosen foods into a plastic dish that
way the experimenters could measure the
amount of each food given now the key is
that each person was under the
impression that the fictional future
participant would have to consume all
the food they dished out for them now
this gave the subject a perfect
opportunity to be nice or nasty
to the anonymous person so what were the
results well those who played as
Superman gave on average nearly twice as
much chocolate as chili sauce for the
future participant to consume whereas on
the other hand those who controlled
Voldemort's were the other way around
they gave on average nearly twice as
much chili sauce and what about the
neutral folks well they were someplace
in the middle dishing out slightly more
chocolate than chili sauce from these
results the researchers concluded that
just five minutes of role-playing in a
virtual environments as either a hero or
villain can easily cause people to
reward or punish anonymous strangers and
that this could be related to the role
they assumed in the video game
one really interesting note that this
research brought up is that it didn't
make any difference if the person's
self-identified with their good or evil
character the research is noted that
this showed that people are prone to be
unaware of the influence of the virtual
representations on their behavioral
responses now some of you might be
thinking well wait a minute
how do we know that this response was
actually down to playing as of a
character couldn't it just as easily be
down to watching and just generally
being exposed to this good or evil
stimuli well the folks at the University
of Illinois thought of that too
so they ran a second trial as well where
they tested exactly this with another
121 individuals this time they also had
people observe others playing as either
of the three avatars and monitored their
actions in the taste test to the results
clearly showed a diminished response
indicating that controlling the good or
evil action was key in passing on the
good or evil real-life behaviors now the
researchers hypothesized that arousal
the degree to which participants are
keyed into the game might be the
important fighter here driving the
behavioural effects they observed
now while this experiment is really
interesting we do have to be a little
careful about drawing to any conclusions
from it for example one thing I would
love to see testing next time is the
effect of time you see the research
paper didn't actually say the exact time
between the five minutes of gaming and
the actual taste test but it was
certainly a short gap but what if the
taste test was taking two hours later or
two days later how long would the impact
of playing a good or evil role in game
continue to affect our real-world
behavior
[Music]
and what about you guys what did you
make of this research and you reckon you
might think differently about next time
you choose good or evil in a game and
also what future research would you like
to see in this area let me know in the
comments last week on reality check I
looked into the real-life possibility of
cloning Big Boss and then the episode I
discussed snakes accelerated aging now a
number of you like all-time Austin on
YouTube asked
I thought Solid Snake aged faster from
Fox died now I did look into this during
the making of the episode and according
to the Metal Gear Solid wiki Fox died
was an engineered retrovirus that was
programmed to kill specific people by
dint affine the person's DNA and their
nano machines and then causing cardiac
arrest however there is no mention of
foxdie affecting his aging this was down
to the deliberate shortening of snakes
telomeres during the cloning process a
concept I discussed in the episode as
always thanks very much for your
thoughts and questions keep them coming
in the comments box or directly on
twitter at camp Fry's Rob also if you
have any topics that you'd love to see
me cover on reality check just let me
know next week all gamespot original
programming is undergoing a schedule
change so from now on you can get your
science hits every Thursday
why Thursday well the name is derived
from the old english Thor's day and Thor
being the god of thunder and thunder
being the noise created by lightning and
lightning being a form of electricity
and electricity powering technology
therefore science see you Thursday
you
[Music]